let's say that we're told that some
angle theta which is going to be
expressed in radians is between negative
3 pi over 2 and
negative pi it's greater than negative 3
pi over 2 it's less than negative pi
and we're also told that sine of theta
is equal to one-half from just from this
information can we figure out what the
tangent of theta is going to be equal to
and i encourage you to pause the video
and try this on your own
in case you're stumped i will give you a
hint you should use the pythagorean
identity the fact that sine squared
theta plus cosine squared theta is equal
to one
so let's do it
so we know the pythagorean identity
sine
squared theta
plus cosine squared theta
is equal to one
we know what sine squared theta is
sine theta is one half so this could be
rewritten as one-half
squared plus cosine squared theta
plus cosine squared theta is equal to
one
or we could write this as one-fourth
plus cosine
plus cosine squared theta
is equal to 1 or we could subtract 1 4
from both sides and we get cosine
squared theta is equal to
see you subtract 1 4 from the left hand
side then this one fourth goes away that
was the whole point one minus one fourth
is three-fourths
is three fourths
so what could cosine of theta be
well when i square it i get positive
three-fourths so it could be the
positive or negative square root of
three-fourths so cosine of theta
cosine of theta
could be equal to the positive or
negative square root
of 3 over 4
of 3 over 4 which is the same thing as
the positive or negative square root of
of 3 over the square root of 4 which is
2. so it's a positive or negative square
root of 3 over 2. but how do we know
which one of these it actually is well
that's where this information becomes
useful that's where this information
actually becomes useful let's draw our
unit circle if you're saying why am i
even worried about cosine theta well if
you know sine of theta you know cosine
of theta tangent of theta is just sine
of theta over cosine theta so then you
will know the tangent of theta but let's
figure out let's look at the unit circle
to figure out which value of cosine we
should use
so let me draw it so unit circle
that's my y-axis
that is my
x-axis
and i will draw the unit circle in pink
so that's my best attempt at drawing a
circle
please forgive me for its lack of
perfect roundness
and
it says theta is between
it's greater than negative 3 pi over 2.
so where is negative 3 pi over 2. so
let's see this is
negative pi over 2 so if this is one
side of the angle let me do this in a
color so let's see this one side of the
angle is going to be along the positive
x-axis and we want to figure out where
the other side is
so it's going to this this right over
here that's negative pi over 2
this is negative
pi
so it's between negative pi which is
right over here so let me make that
clear negative pi
is
right over here it's between negative pi
and
negative 3 pi over 2 negative 3 pi over
2 is right
negative 3 pi over 2 is right over here
so the angle
our angle theta our angle theta is going
to put us someplace
someplace over here
someplace
over here and the whole reason i did
this so this whole arc right here
you could think of this as
as the measure of angle theta right over
there and the whole reason i did that is
to think about whether the cosine of
theta is going to be positive or
negative we clearly see it's in the
second quadrant the cosine of theta is
the x-coordinate of this point where our
angle intersects the unit circle
so this point right over here
this right over here
actually let me do it in that orange
color again this right over here that is
the cosine
of theta now is that a positive or
negative value well it's clearly a
negative value so for the sake of this
example our cosine theta our cosine
theta is not the positive one it is the
negative one so we can write that cosine
theta is equal to the negative square
root of 3 over 2.
so we figured out cosine theta but we
still have to figure out tangent of
theta and we just have to remind
ourselves that the tangent of theta is
going to be equal to the sine of theta
sine of theta
sine of theta over the cosine of theta
over the cosine of theta well they told
us the sine of theta is one half so it's
going to be one half over cosine of
theta which is negative square root of
three over two
negative square root of three over two
and what does that equal well that's the
same thing as one half
times the reciprocal of this so times
negative
negative two
over the square root of three
these twos will cancel out and we are
left with negative one over the square
root of three
now some people don't like a radical in
the denominator like this they don't
like an irrational
denominator so we could rationalize the
denominator here by multiplying by
square root of 3 over square root of 3
square root of 3
over square root of 3 and so that gets
us this will be equal to negative square
root of 3
over 3 is the tangent is the tangent of
this
is the tangent of this angle
of this angle
right over here and that actually makes
sense because the tangent of the angle
is the slope
of this line and we see that it is
indeed a negative a negative slope